views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
i'm not bluffing i'm not playing a game
tonight on politics now governor steve
siselak tells nevadans to stay home for
two more weeks
the consequences if we don't follow the
rules
we've been getting our bug here a blunt
assessment from sheriff joe lombardo how
metro police is dealing with covid19
within the department
and the results will soon be final clark
county wraps up its ballot count from
the election
while the trump administration disputes
the results
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler stay home
again governor steve siselak issues a
two-week request for everyone to
quarantine
as the coronavirus spreads governor
steve sisilak says monday marked the
highest hospitalization rate in the
state since mid-august
and if things don't change in the next
two weeks he'll be forced to take
stronger actions
in the next two weeks two weeks
we must see a significant reversal of
the current trends
which are deeply concerning now nevadans
need to operate in the stay-at-home 2.0
mentality
to get things under control so our
public health
response infrastructure can catch up
we need that time to bring testing
timelines down
catch up on contact racing and relieve
our health care infrastructure system
governor sislak encouraged people to
work from home
continue social distancing and wear a
mask in public
in reno hospitals there are at or near
patient capacity
southern nevada hospitals though put out
a joint statement saying they're
at lower capacity than they were at the
same time last year
but they're encouraging you to take care
of your normal medical needs
and your elective surgeries so how can
the state
ask us to stay home while businesses
that keep the state moving stay
open i spoke with clark county
commission chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick
how are you gonna be able to walk that
balance and walk that fine line
so we've been walking that balance for a
very long time and we have to look at
public health bars
but public health also is economic
and social health and mental health
so we are um look we have a bunch of
great folks here in clark county they've
really been stepping up and doing the
extra efforts
i get that people are covet fatigue i
think we could all
agree to that but we're going into flu
season now
and we really have to make sure that our
behaviors
are top-notch i mean this is the time we
always knew that
as the weather got colder that
we would see more cases um because
that's just naturally what happens to us
during flu season so
what i would tell you is the best thing
that we can all do to keep businesses
open
to keep our community healthy
is to just pay extra special attention
to
washing your hands wearing a face mask
and social distancing in that
and i'm confident that we value staying
open that we can do that
um in the next few weeks is it possible
for clark county to
step in and close businesses on its own
again
so we have um so we have uh
we've been shutting down businesses that
have not been complying not trying to
comply
uh for the last i don't know seven
months
so we did have a small miscommunication
of whose jurisdiction was what but i'll
tell you that
all of the business licensing across the
valley
including osha gaming control board
the athletic commission are all uh
meeting once a week
and we're uh looking at where our
problems are
i guess i meant more broadly if there
was going to be i remember the governor
had the phases
early on in the pandemic is it possible
that
clark county could on its own if cases
continue to increase and there's more of
a public health concern
step in and shut down let's say
bars or restaurants or close down
gyms and athletic facilities things
along those lines we can always be more
restrictive
than the governor's directive we can
also go to the mitigation task force and
recommend
some some of those closures but i can
tell you this has been very hard for
everybody
you know we have to balance people being
able to pay their bills
as well as businesses who are trying to
stay afloat
during these tough times and so
i'm just hoping that with the public
health that people will really
um really pay attention so you know some
of the things that we're seeing are
unregulated businesses that are creating
the problem you know so
whether it's a group of people getting
on a bus and renting a house and
partying all night with no face mask or
whether it's
your law firm that's posting a luncheon
with no social distancing no face masks
no washing your hands
those are the things that i need people
to pay attention to
um for the next three to four months
because it is our flu season and we
always have to make sure that our
hospitals do not get overrun
if a community the size of clark county
has unused funds
if there's a need to ask for more
federal assistance for example if if the
money that's already been dished out
hasn't all been used
do you need would there be a need for
more here's what i would tell you it's
apples and oranges because the dollars
that we got today were specifically
to building the needs of a community
uh during these times but for local
government in particular
and state government there's a lost
revenue component
because this money has to be expended by
december 30th
so we know that january 1st there's
going to be tons of evictions that are
on the
chopping block we know that coronavirus
we're still going to be in the middle of
it until we can get
the vaccine here so we're still going to
have needs and with that lost revenue
on the local and state level we we still
have to provide
service so when times are bad we provide
lots of service when times are good we
still have to provide service
the legislative session won't be easy
either funding wise uh
down the pipe no and we get a large um
portion of our social service dollars
from the state
so we are watching that very closely
because
we still have to provide all those
services as for again that question
about the extra
funding that clark county is uh going to
discuss uh this coming week at tuesday's
meeting
that is federal money uh 294 million
dollars or so and that some of it just
wasn't used yet
if you want more details on that and the
full interview with commissioner
kirkpatrick
just head to 8newsnow.com this week
president-elect joe biden began
releasing details on how his
administration will tackle the kovit-19
pandemic
he says stopping the spread of the virus
is the most important thing
and that will help revitalize our
economy washington bureau correspondent
alexander limon has a reaction to his
plan from business groups
president-elect joe biden says his
national strategy for things like a
rapid coveted testing program
will save lives and the economy so that
we can reopen our businesses
safely and sustainably resume our lives
put our put this pandemic behind us
forty percent of excess unemployment is
in the travel industry
tori emerson barnes says the u.s travel
association has been calling for a
federal testing strategy
for months it can really help to give
folks confidence
um to travel again in a more robust way
and so
we absolutely would support these kinds
of practices being implemented across
the country
the u.s chamber of commerce also wants
to see the federal government
issue a standard set of cobit 19
guidelines to be used around the country
so that on a local level officials know
what steps to take
that can best minimize the spread of
covet and
also minimize economic shutdowns
neil bradley with the chamber of
commerce says the national strategy
needs to be science and data
driven we believe the key to getting the
economy back to where we wanted to be
which is
where we were before we ever heard of
covet is beating this virus and getting
control
of the spread in washington alexandra
limon
president-elect joe biden has outlined
plans for his incoming administration
on the coronavirus response what are
some differences right now between
what the current administration is doing
and what the future administration is
going to do yeah what we've seen the
trump administration
do is kind of allow the coronavirus
pandemic
rules regulations to be handled on a
state-by-state basis allowing governors
to issue their own rules
and while that's sort of how it has to
happen because of just the kind of
political system that we have set up in
the united states joe biden wants to
try to implement a more national
strategic plan so for example instead of
waiting for states to request tests he
says he wants to provide all of the
states a lot more
access to rapid testing so that people
can get tested right away
in a quick manner when they feel they
need it or they have concerns or
questions about whether they could have
been possibly infected with
covet 19. he also for example wants
americans across the country to wear
mass joe biden does
and we've heard him talk about that in
the past but while he says he can't
issue a
nationwide mandate he says he does want
to work
with all governors around the country to
get them to
issue state mandates if they don't
already have them in place where on the
other hand you know we've kind of seen
president trump
take a more laid-back approach and say
you know whatever these governors want
to do that's fine so
some very definite differences there
thank you very much for the latest from
washington dc alexander limon thanks for
joining us
so among those on the front line dealing
with coronavirus are police officers
on our morning cup of joe's segment i
spoke with sheriff joe lobardo from
metro police
about how the department is handling the
epidemic
we've talked also before about covet 19
and the effect on the department we've
we know about it's already hit close to
home not only for you personally but for
the department is in general
what the coronavirus has done what is
the latest on cases officer wellness
within
in the department it's not going the
right direction so in the last three
weeks we
for lack of a better way to describe it
we've been getting our bug kicked
we're averaging between 5 and 10
positive
employees on a daily basis
if you look at our total numbers since
the beginning of march we're right
around 460
positive employees so with my total
workforce
if you did you did the math on that it's
around seven percent positive
um compared to the workforce uh so the
the benchmark for the
state and the county is eight percent so
we're below that benchmark
and which is important to evaluate
because
we have a little more interaction with
the general public than most people do
and so it's not like we can work from
home
in that vein so i think we're doing a
pretty good job
um addressing it on a daily basis basis
but
we have concerns in the back of my mind
personally that those numbers are going
to continue to increase
because the particular problem with it
is it's not only the positive employees
is to contact
tracing and there are other employees
that have to be quarantined
that were in close proximity of the
positive employee and that number is
hovering right around 300
in today's number so if you if you think
about
a cop responding to a call for service
you know
we we have to back all that up with uh
overtime
and you know the budget budget concerns
and you know that's my job that's
something i have to worry about and
that's what i get paid to do
um but it's important for the public to
realize what's going on so if if as you
say
covet is as you said kicking the
department's butt right now
what can be done it's not like you can
arrest someone while being socially
distant
what measures are being taken at metro
we just got to ensure you know the
mandate that i put forward on
pp and e um that the officers continue
to do that you know
and sometimes it's a simple thing as is
when they're at home
a family member get becomes positive and
they become positive so they have to be
aware of that
and even at work you know even having
lunch with the
fellow employees they have to be aware
of their social distancing and washing
their hands
and all those things we they constantly
have to be reminded of those
you know triage methods that they have
to be aware of and we continue in that
vein because
until a vaccine appears miraculously
we're going to have to deal with it on a
daily basis
coming up next on politics now it's
almost official
the final steps to putting the november
election in the books
welcome back to politics now
the final election results are all
counted so here's an
update on a few close races here in
southern nevada
democrat ross miller hung on to beat
republican stavros anthony in the race
for clark county commission district c
the difference just about 570 votes
that is to fill an open seat on the
commission there are a few seats with
big implications at the legislature
first
state senate majority leader nicole
cannazzaro hung on to her seat in
district six
beating republican april becker by about
800 votes
canazarro was down after some of the
initial results
also in the state senate democrat
christy watson beat republican carrie
buck
in district five by 200 votes that is
also an open seat that was previously
held by a democrat
in state assembly district 37 andy
matthews beat incumbent democrat shea
bakus the difference there
fewer than 600 votes so the votes are
all counted here in clark county next up
is
the canvassing provisional ballots and
any signature curing
wrapped up by midnight on thursday in
clark county the provisional ballots
include people who registered to vote on
election day
however nevada's secretary of state's
office is still verifying some of those
registrations
and there are still legal challenges to
the election from president trump's
campaign
here in clark county we have registrar
of voters joe gloria
i have no information on exactly what
they've identified as those ballots but
we'll certainly look into it if they
give it to us unfortunately they don't
give those reports to us
they're just going out to the media
unfortunately there's a lot of
misinformation
that's being put out there but i have
consistently
communicated to the general public and
the media that any
instance or regulatory that has been
pointed out to us has
we've come up with an answer to explain
exactly why those occurred
we will continue to do so all those vote
totals are expected to be certified by
clark county monday afternoon
candidates then get three days to
request a recount the county has to
finish a recount then within five
days asian american and pacific
islanders are the fastest growing ethnic
group nationwide
and nevada they are also growing the
fastest so
how did they vote in the last
presidential election well
apia vote says there were about 209
000 eligible aapi asian pacific islander
voters here in nevada
that's about 11 percent of our eligible
voters the group says their exit polling
shows they voted for
former vice president joe biden 58
percent to 40 percent for president
trump
full-time distance learning across most
of the clark county school district
trustees postponed a vote on ccsd's
plans to bring students back to class
sasha loftus explains why i think that
they did the right thing
by tabling the discussion parents
jeffrey and emily balcom
share their thoughts on the latest clark
county school district discussion
so i want families and students to know
that i recognize their struggles but i
also recognize this decision is too
important to rush
in thursday's virtual meeting ccsd
leaders postponed a vote to transition
to hybrid learning
citing a recent spike in kovid 19
numbers
we need to have a plan where people
are volunteering to go in without
worrying about
losing their lives the 205 page plan
would have gone into effect in january
but with the governor's latest
suggestion to stay home
that vote was tabled until further
notice there is more work to be done
and if this board's inability to make a
decision
has now hampered that we are hurting our
children
even more while it's clear some are
against the plan to postpone
the balcom say now is not the time to
make a definite decision
we couldn't make a decision as parents
because i don't know what as
dr jarvis said tonight he doesn't have a
crystal ball they say they're
willing to hold off until they know
their kids are safe
i think the best decision for for
parents and families and teachers
is going to end up being the most
informed decision and we have to wait
sasha loftis 8 news now the trustees did
not choose a future date to vote on this
plan again so it's actually unclear
if or when it will come up for
discussion one more time
coming up next on politics now veterans
advocates are pressing members of
congress
to pass legislation that could help
veterans
exposed to toxic burn pits i'm kelly
meyer reporting from washington
why they're asking lawmakers to get
these veterans the benefit
you're watching politics now
[Music]
wednesday was veterans day here in the
u.s there was a ceremony in boulder city
over at the southern nevada veterans
memorial cemetery you're seeing there
1440 flags placed on the gravesites of
all
fallen veterans thousands of veterans
are waiting for help after being exposed
to
toxic burn pits the department of
veterans affairs has denied about 78
percent of disability claims related to
this exposure
as kelly kelly meyer tells us veterans
and lawmakers are not taking no for an
answer
due to the pandemic comedian john
stewart's latest push to support
veterans
is happening virtually hey everybody
it's jon stewart
hi everybody john field after working
with john field to secure
funding for 9 11 first responders it
really is an urgency
this is not normal they're now helping
victims of toxic burn pits
facing barriers to va benefits the va
should be acting
on behalf of the veterans not as an
obstacle the v.a says all veterans of
operations iraqi and enduring freedom
are eligible for five years of free va
health care regardless of service
connection
in the last 13 years 78 percent of
disability claims related to toxic
exposure have been rejected by the va
they've been denied
routinely new york democratic senator
kirsten gillibrand
introduced legislation to make it easier
for victims to get benefits
north carolina republican senator tom
tillis has his own separate legislation
to create an independent commission to
investigate allegations of toxic
exposure from troops and veterans what
we need
is not a study or discretion what we
need
is a presumptive benefit gillibrand says
she's working to get her legislation
passed before the end of the year
if it doesn't phil and stuart say
they'll be back
it's going to take everybody everybody
we always have our eye on you know what
the goal is
reporting in washington i'm kelly meyer
burn pits have long been an issue in
fact it's how
the existence of area 51 was first
revealed to the rest of the world
workers at area 51 said they were
exposed to toxic fumes from burn pits
at the secret military base then called
the nevada test site
employees were trying to get
compensation from the federal government
after contracting diseases like copd
it was that fight which sparked the
first reporting on area 51 by our own
items george knapp
decades ago in this week's what to watch
we are keeping a close eye on the
coronavirus cases here in nevada
governor steve sisolak threatened that
he would take stronger actions if the
number of cases did not start to go back
down the number of hospitalizations key
to that as well
also the canvassing of the election
takes place this upcoming week
county boards will meet and discuss any
problems with provisional ballots
signatures that don't match or other
issues in clark county
this decision this discussion rather
will be on monday in the commission
chambers
and then they'll put the state's final
seal of approval on the november general
election results
thank you very much for watching
politics now here on 8 news now for all
the latest election news just head to
8newsnow.com
and you can check us out there we're
back on saturday
[Music]
[Music]
you